[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Welcome to our
fourth problem session.
We're going to be talking about
binary trees mostly, today.
We'll talk a little bit
about binary heaps, which
is a topic we won't
cover until next Tuesday,
but it will appear
in very small ways
on your problem set 4, which
will be due next Friday.
So I'm going to go over a little
bit of that material today.
But it's mostly concerning--
the subject material for
today is mostly binary trees,
specifically, being applied
to set data structures
and sequence data structures,
as Professor Demaine talked
to you earlier this week.
But for now-- actually,
as of yesterday--
you've seen all of the data
structures that we're going
to cover to--
that will implement the set
interface and the sequence
interface.
Those nice tables that Professor
Demaine has been showing you,
those are now complete.
We have some data
structures that
are really good-- constant time
operations for some operations.
So we might use them
for some applications.
And this week, we've
been describing
to you trees, which
achieve, really, pretty
good, for any type of
query operation on my sets
or sequences--
pretty good meaning logarithmic
time, not quite constant.
But for our purposes, log n is--
I mean, on your
computer, practically--
not asymptotically,
but practically-- log
n is going to be at most
what on your computer?
Something like 64, right?
Any input that you're operating
on with, in machine words,
is your input.
You need to be able to
address all those machine
words in your input.
And on your computer, the size
of your machine word addresses
is 64 bits, right?
And we assume that the
word size is at least
log the size of your input so
that you can address the input.
So for your purposes,
on your computer,
log n is going to
be no more than 64,
which means you would get
maybe a 50 times overhead,
or for smaller instances,
it could be more like 10,
if you've got 1,000 things
that you're working on.
It's not that bad, right?
It's a constant-- it's not
a constant factor for theory
purposes, but for your purposes,
log n is much better than
a polynomial factor--
another factor of n.
You've seen all of the code.
You've seen implementations of
all of these set and sequence
interfaces, right?
So I went ahead and
wrote a little--
I compiled all of that code
from your recitation notes,
of all of the different
interface implementations.
And what I did was, I
wrote a little test program
to see how they ran
on a real machine.
I have a little test code here.
I have a little folder that
lists an array implementing
a sequence, a binary
tree implementing
a sequence, a dynamic
array implementing--
all of these kinds of things.
Then set things-- a sorted array
being a set in a binary tree,
and a hash table.
These are our implementations.
I'm not using Python
dictionaries for hash tables,
I'm using the implementations
that are in your recitation.
And I'm going to
run this little test
efficiency Python code
that basically is just
going to free each one.
It's going to do a bunch of
these different operations
and measure to see
how much time it took.
I'm just logging how
much time it took.
It's not an asymptotic
analysis, but hopefully, we
see some separation.
So when you press that,
it runs a bunch of tests.
Let's take a look.
OK.
I've got a bunch of
sequence operations.
We've got build, set_at,
get-at, insert, delete,
at the various places.
And these are the actual
timings to some scale--
to some resolution that I had
for these data structures.
And you can see build--
actually, build,
on this machine,
just allocating some
array and clearing it,
is a really efficient thing that
Python is going to do for me.
And so that's actually-- it's
mislabelling that as log n.
But these other things,
get_at and set_at--
really, really fast, right?
That's constant time.
And then these other
things, I essentially
can't do better than
loop through the thing,
and so it takes linear time.
And again, sequence stuff,
setting_at and getting_at
is slow, but deleting and
removing from the first thing,
I'm just re-linking
the pointer, right?
Dynamic arrays.
Again, set_at, get_at is
fast, because it's just
regular arrays.
And then inserting-
and deleting-last,
that's getting,
essentially, constant time.
Now, I'm actually-- when I'm
running these tests to deal
with averages, I'm
actually running
these things, a lot of times,
and testing their performance.
And so I'm not seeing the
worst case happen here, right?
I'm averaging over all
of the things, which
is exactly what
amortization means.
That's why I'm getting
good performance here.
A hash table.
Again, really--
oh, so this is what
we talked about
in problem session
last week, implementing
kind of a double-ended queue
with a hash table.
This is that implementation.
I just wanted to show it to you.
But it's actually pretty good.
This is what JavaScript
uses for arrays.
And then a binary sequence
represented as a binary tree--
a balanced binary tree.
This is our AVL code that I had.
And all of the other things
have been really pretty bad
at insert_at and
delete_at, but this one
does comparable to all
of the other things.
Now, you see these are a
little bit more machine
cycles than the other things,
but not so bad, actually.
And then, on the
set side of things,
again, we had a sorted array.
Sorry, this is a
set from an array.
Basically, it's
an unsorted array.
I'm just looking for all of the
things-- that's very bad times.
Sorted array does these
find operations great,
but inserting and
deleting is poor.
That's why we need binary trees.
Hash tables get good dictionary
operations, but really
bad order operations.
And then the binary search
tree, a set binary tree, again,
does quite good on
all of these things.
In fact, it's getting
really quite good--
it's getting better,
for some reason,
than the sorted array even did.
I don't know why.
Our implementations are
not optimized at all.
But it does pretty
well asymptotically.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could
you explain again
why the first data
treasury [INAUDIBLE] log n?
JASON KU: This is just
labeled based off the timings.
It happens to be that,
probably, there's
a C intrinsic underneath Python
that allocates this thing,
and so it does it really fast.
My program that's
looking at these numbers
and trying to guess what the
asymptotic running time is,
these are just labels based
on these things, ranges.
I just-- it's mischaracterized.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
Well, I mean, in actuality,
if it was C code--
if all of this stuff
was in C, probably,
we would see that bar be
longer, because it's actually
having to go through and
touch all of that memory.
It's still doing that here,
but all of the Python stuff
is super crufty.
It's, like, 100 times slower
than anything that C does.
And so you're seeing
that disparity.
Does that make sense?
OK.
I just wanted to show you that.
We might release this for
you to play around with,
but just wanted to give
you a taste of that.
OK, any questions
before we move on?
How do I turn this off?
Up, and off.
Shut down.
Yes.
OK.
Moving on to problems--
working some problems.
You have your set
of problems here.
The first one is, we're going
to look at a sequence AVL tree.
This is a sequence AVL tree.
How do I know that?
You don't, necessarily.
But these things
are certainly not
in sorted order of the things
I'm storing in them, Yeah?
So it had better not
be a set AVL tree.
Is it an AVL tree?
Is it balanced--
height balanced?
Yeah, basically.
Actually, if you compute
the size of each subtree,
the left and right subtrees
on all of these-- you
can confirm for
yourself-- are balanced.
They're within plus or
minus 1 of each other.
Actually, this is about
as far away from balanced
as you could get
for this many nodes
while still maintaining
height balance--
maintaining AVL
property-- which is why
this is an instructive example.
It's kind of at the limit.
And what am I going to do?
What's missing in this
picture if I'm claiming
this is a sequence AVL tree?
Any ideas what's missing?
What does the sequence AVL
tree store that I'm not
showing in this picture?
AUDIENCE: Counts.
JASON KU: What?
JASON KU: Counts.
And?
It's a sequence AVL tree.
Heights, right?
Sequence AVL trees,
different than set AVL trees,
are augmented by
two things, right?
Because I need to be
maintaining balance during
rotations, and so I
need to store heights.
I need to be able to tell what
the heights of these subtrees
are in constant time
when I'm walking up
the tree, fixing things.
And the sequence requires me
to store their subtree numbers
there.
I don't know-- I'm
not going to draw it
for all of these things, but
how about for number four?
What's its height?
1, 2, 3.
That's the longest path from
the root subtree of that.
So this is height equals 3.
That came from height equals
2 and height equals 1.
Does everyone see that?
Yeah?
And then the size
here, how big is that?
That's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
This is-- I'm going to
put size equals 7 here.
And that's coming from
this guy, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And this guy is 2.
So how do I compute
the subtree size?
It's my left subtree size plus
my right subtree size plus 1.
And my height is taking
the max of the 2 plus 1.
All right.
So we did all that yesterday.
I'm just labeling these things.
And what I'm asking of you is
to perform a delete operation.
This is a sequence tree.
So I'm finding things by
their index in the tree.
So I'm going to ask you
to delete the eighth thing
in my sequence.
What is the 8th
thing in my sequence?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify,
since delete-8 is not delete
the number.
JASON KU: Correct.
Well, delete_at 8.
Do you see that?
It's a sequence operation.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
So this is very
important, that you
differentiate between
sequence and set semantics.
If I'm dealing
with the sequence,
I had better not be
looking up intrinsic things
on this data structure, because
it's not an intrinsic data
structure.
It doesn't support that.
If I wanted to support find,
say, the index of key 8,
or something like that,
then all I could do
is-- it's similar to an array.
I would just have to loop
through the whole sequence
and tell me if the
thing is in it.
Can't really do better
than linear time.
This data structure is
not designed for that.
What is it designed for?
It's designed to find things
by their index in the sequence.
So how do I find the 8th index?
Well, I mean, I'm
looking at the tree,
and I can just count
along in-order traversal.
What's the in-order traversal?
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
OK, found 8.
But what does a
sequence AVL tree do?
I'm storing subtree
sizes, and when I'm here,
I don't know what index I'm at.
How can I find out what
index I'm at from the root?
I look at my left subtree,
see how many it is.
There are seven things here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Yeah.
Because I'm looking for
the 9th item by index 8.
This is saying that
I'm the 8th item.
I'm the guy at index 7.
Does that make sense?
Because I'm looking at
the subtree size here.
So what do I know?
I know that the index that I'm
looking for is to my right.
I go down over here
and I happen to know--
what index am I looking
for in this subtree?
0, right?
I want the first
thing in the subtree.
My search index has changed
now, because I essentially dealt
with all of those eight items.
Here, I'm looking for the
0th thing in my index.
I look to my left--
if I didn't have a left subtree,
I would be the 0th thing,
and I would return me.
But there is stuff in here.
So I'm looking for the 0th thing
in here, which is just him,
and I return it.
And actually, what I'm
doing is, I'm deleting it.
So I delete it.
Yuck.
What's the problem here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Not height balanced.
What's not height balanced here?
AUDIENCE: The left subtree is--
or, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: This guy is not
height balanced, right?
AUDIENCE: --right subtree
of the right [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: This guy's subtree
is not height balanced, right?
This guy's 2.
This guy's 1.
So how do we fix it?
AUDIENCE: Rotate.
JASON KU: We do some rotations.
This is actually
the bad case that--
the third bad case that
we talked about yesterday.
If I tried to just
left-rotate this guy,
what would it look like?
It would put 12 here.
It would put 10 here.
And 8 would be attached to that.
Now it's height balanced wrong
in the other direction, right?
That's no good.
So the way to handle
this case, where
I am badly skewed to the
right but my right subtree
is skewed to the left, I
have to do a rotation here,
right rotation, and
then do a rotation.
That's the formula.
Here, we first do
a right rotation
at 10, which gives me something
that looks like 8, 10.
Now, obviously, this is not
better than what was before,
but it was an intermediate
step so that we can fix it.
We right-rotate here and
then we left-rotate here.
The default is that we
would left-rotate here,
but because this had the
skew in the wrong direction,
I need to right-rotate this one
first and then we can do it.
So now I rotate
all of these guys
over and put 12 down
here, 8 here, 10 here.
Everyone see that that's
what a rotation looks like?
OK.
It takes a little while to get
your mind wrapped around what
the transformation is, but
hopefully, you guys all
followed that transformation.
There was a little magic
while I was trying to draw.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I still don't
feel like this tree is
height balanced.
JASON KU: It's not.
Good observation.
Why is that?
This thing still has height 3.
What is the height
of this thing?
1, right?
This is height 1.
And actually, when I
was doing that rotation,
I needed to update all
of these augmentations.
Which augmentations
did I really need
to-- which subtrees have
changed during those things?
I don't remember what
the thing looked like.
What did the thing look like?
10 had 8 in its subtree, so
its subtree definitely changed.
8's subtree changed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: 12 didn't change--
eventually.
AUDIENCE: These are
10 and 8 [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: OK.
So there's the case analysis
that's in your lecture notes
and was done in recitation.
It tells you that
these A, B, C, D
kind of subtress,
the ones that could
change in these things,
those subtrees don't change.
The only subtree that
changed during one
of these fix operations, when
you do one or two rotations,
is either two nodes
or three nodes
whose subtree has changed.
Here, it could have been the
case that three subtrees have
changed.
But in the easy case, only
two nodes-- x and y, I think,
in the notes--
could have changed.
And so when I do that, I have
to recompute their augmentations
from their augmentations
of their children,
but it's only a constant
number of those,
so I just recompute them,
because the subtrees below me
haven't changed.
OK.
So we have a height
mismatch here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Right.
So, originally,
in the picture, 12
has a bunch of things
in its subtree--
10 and 8, and we just deleted 7.
So its subtree
definitely changed.
There used to be three--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Oh, no, sorry, it did.
Yeah.
So here, three node
subtrees have changed.
But that's actually the most.
I'm showing you the worst case.
Only three nodes
possible in doing
one of these
double-rotation things
could have changed
their subtrees.
And so we just have to fix the
augmentation of those three
things.
In the easy case,
it's just two things.
All right.
We have unbalanced.
How can we fix this?
I could have been mean.
I want to be able to
right-rotate here,
to re-balance I could have been
mean and switched these two.
If I switched those
two, then I would
have to do two rotations
to fix this thing,
because the middle one is
heavier than the left one
against what I'm doing.
But I'm not that mean, so
I'm going to right-rotate.
How do I do that?
Well, a right-rotate
at 6 is going
to bring all of
this down below 4
and stick this subtree
as the left child of 6.
Does that makes sense?
Yuck.
That's going to be fun to draw.
I'm just going to redraw it.
That makes more sense, right?
4, 11, 3, 2, 1, and
then 6, 5, 9, 8, 12, 10.
That's the right rotation at 6.
Is everyone cool with this?
The rotation-- my
x is 6, my y is 4.
I have A, B, C subtrees.
What I'm doing is kind of
switching which of x and y
is the root here.
So now y is the root, and B
and C subtrees here now become
the children of x underneath y.
And notice that, hopefully,
through all of that process,
my in-order traversal
has not changed.
We had to update our
augmentations along the way,
but it's a constant every
time we walk up the tree.
And we walk up the tree only
a logarithmic number of times.
Yeah?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So every time we do a
rotation, do you just
update the augmentation
via the [INAUDIBLE]
before we do any other rotation?
JASON KU: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: The second part.
Updating the
augmentation just means
updating the count, and
the height, and just,
the properties that stay--
JASON KU: Yeah.
Basically what we
did, we defined--
when we augmented--
Professor Demaine
yesterday defined for you
what a subtree property is.
It meant a property
that I can compute only
by looking at my children--
the augmentations of my
children, recursively.
So here, instead of
trying to increment or try
to think about, locally, what
this augmentation should be,
I'm going to throw away
my old augmentation
and just recompute
it from my children,
because those, recursively,
had better be correct.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So just looking
at how the rotation works.
I'm having trouble
wrapping my head around.
So basically, you're swapping
4 and 6, and that way,
4 becomes the parent node
and 6 becomes the right node.
JASON KU: I'm going
to draw this picture.
It's just something
you've got to memorize.
This is x, B, C, and A.
Can you see that picture?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: What?
JASON KU: Yeah.
It's in your notes.
It's not a big deal.
But if you've got
this structure,
where x has a left child--
and these subtrees
may be empty or not.
Doesn't really matter.
What I can do is, I can
move from here to there--
has the same in-order
traversal order,
but it's got a different shape.
And in particular,
subtree heights
have changed, which means it
can help us re-balance the tree.
And that's the
whole point of AVL.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: That's
the right rotation?
JASON KU: This one is--
this is a right rotation.
This is a left rotation.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: As I'm
walking up the tree,
every node I might have
to fix with a re-balance,
but that re-balance does
at most two rotations,
and there is at most log
n ancestors that I have,
because my tree was
height balanced at 2
log n or something like that.
Which means that,
at max, I might
have to do four log n rotations,
because each one could
do two rotations.
Does that makes sense?
Now, in actuality, you can prove
that, in a delete operation,
it's possible that you have
to do a logarithmic number
of these rotations up the tree.
This was that bad case.
The original tree I gave you
is called a Fibonacci tree.
It's the few-- it's the
highest height balanced tree
you can have on a
given number of nodes.
Yeah, the fewest nodes
for a certain height.
You can think of it either way.
And if you generalize that
to a large enough thing,
then that thing will
take a logarithmic number
of rotations going up.
Now, actually,
with an insertion,
you can actually prove-- you can
go through the case analysis.
An insertion operation will
always re-balance the tree
after one re-balance
operation, which
could include two rotations.
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
Right rotation, this guy
becomes a right child.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So can you not-- are there
certain rotations that you
can't perform, depending on
whether you had a child--
JASON KU: Yeah.
If I didn't have a left subtree,
can't perform a right rotation
there.
A right rotation necessitates
that I have a left child.
So if you're doing it--
and you'll see,
our code actually
checks to make sure
you have a left child.
That's an assertion
that you might
want to fire before you ever
do one of these rotations.
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just to
reiterate, so an insertion
may take two rotations
at most [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: Mhm.
A constant number of
rotations, and the deletion
could take a logarithmic
number of rotations.
Now, that's not something
you need to know.
It's not something I'm
proving here to you.
Just something
that's interesting.
There are rebalancing
schemes, like in CRS.
They introduce a red-black
tree to introduce balance.
And those trees actually
have a weaker bound on--
it's not as tightly
balanced as an AVL tree is.
It allows higher than skew 2.
And because it's kind
of a weaker restriction,
they get away with only doing a
constant number of rotations--
that they can afford that
before they fix the tree.
But a little more complicated.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Very nice.
OK.
Any questions on this?
OK, so now, this is more of
a mechanical question you'll
get on your problem sets.
And now we get more on to
the theory-type questions.
These are going to be a
reduction-type questions.
OK.
This first problem, Fick Nury.
This is-- anyone?
Nick Fury, right?
So it's an Avengers reference.
So basically, what
happens in this thing,
he's got a list of
superheroes that each
have an opinion on whether
they should go fight Sanos.
And their opinion can
be strongly positive
or strongly negative.
And so what Fick
is trying to do is
find, from among
his Revengers, what
the log n most extreme-opinion
Revengers are so
that he can talk to them.
He doesn't want to
talk to everybody.
He wants to talk to a
logarithmic number of them.
OK.
It's kind of-- whatever.
Basically, we have a
classified situation
where you're given, as a
read-only input data store
of these things in an array.
And I want to find the log
n ones with the strongest
opinions.
Does that make sense?
And I want to do it--
and the first problem
is in linear time.
You actually don't know
how to do this yet.
You'll know how to do it with
material that you cover in--
well, they teach you
one way to do it in 046,
but we're not going to
get you there right now.
We'll teach you another
way to do it on Tuesday,
which is via binary heaps.
Binary heaps are an
interesting thing.
It implements a subset
of the set interface.
Really, it just-- you can
build on some iterable x.
I collect a bunch of things.
These items have keys.
It's a key data structure
in the same way.
It's implementing what we call
a priority queue interface.
I can build these things.
I can insert things, but I'm
not going to do that here.
All I really need here,
for this situation,
is a delete_superlative
kind of operation--
in this case, probably max.
Delete_max.
So this is like--
I've got a data structure,
I'm calling these things.
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's
a priority queue?
JASON KU: Yes.
A priority queue is
essentially something that
implements these two things.
Actually, there's a third one
where I can insert a new thing,
but I'm not going to
need that right now.
So that's what a
priority queue is.
And actually, a set--
this is a subset of
the set interface.
Right?
The nice thing about a heap--
which, I won't to show
you how it's done,
but what a heap can do--
if I had both of these
operations implemented
using a set AVL tree, how long
would these things take me?
How long does it take
to build a set AVL tree?
n log n, right?
Because essentially, I'm
getting a sorted order
out of this thing if I'm
inserting these things
one at a time--
or I could sort them,
and then put them
in a tree in linear time,
like you saw a couple of days
ago in recitation.
But I have to sort them
at some point, right?
I'm kind of--
I need to take at
least n log n time,
because if I'm going to be able
to return their traversal order
in linear time, and I have
this lower bound of n log
n on sorting, I kind of needed
to spend n log n time here,
right?
And how long would
this delete_max take?
AUDIENCE: It's sorted, so log n.
JASON KU: Log n, right?
So it's a set AVL tree.
Where is my max?
It's the right-most thing.
I can just walk down
the thing, take it off.
Maybe I have to re-balance.
But that's a log n operation.
It's the same as
insert-last in my subtree.
For a set AVL tree,
this is n log n.
This is log n.
Now, there's another data
structure that does better
for one of these operations.
And the same for the other one
that we've learned earlier.
Anyone remember?
Set AVL tree didn't
actually give us
anything over a sorted
array in a dynamic array.
What that did was, we have a--
we could sort it in n log n time
using merge sort or something
like that.
And then we could just pop
off the last one n times.
That would be an amortized--
I mean, if I didn't
care about taking up
that size, I could do it, in
worst case, constant time.
I just read off the
first-- the last one.
I don't need to resize
the array, ever.
I can just ignore that.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
But that's-- OK.
If I had a data structure
that implemented these two
operations, can someone
tell me an algorithm
to generate fixed lists--
don't worry about running
time right now-- but that
just uses these two operations?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we build
this data structure.
It's ordered from
least to greatest
toward absolute value of x.
JASON KU: Don't worry
about where things are
ordered or anything like that.
I don't tell you how these
things are implemented, right?
All I'm saying is, I can
accept a bunch of these things,
and I can remove the
maximum and return it.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I think
we just build it--
make sure that you build it
such that the opinion levels are
the absolute value of
the opinion levels, not--
JASON KU: Sure.
OK.
So that's a nice thing.
What I'm going to do, as
your colleague is saying,
is, I'm going to look through
all of the things in my input.
I'm going to copy it over to
some writable memory store.
That read-only thing is
not relevant to this part
of the problem.
What I'm going to do is--
right.
Sorry.
I'm thinking about your
problem set that we're writing.
I'm mixing it up.
OK, so we copy it over to
our new linear-sized array.
But instead of putting
their values there,
I'm going to put the absolute
values of their values.
Does that make sense?
I just check if it's negative.
If it is, I put the
positive thing there.
OK?
And then I stick that
array in this build.
I put that there.
That will take some--
whatever this build time is.
And then I can
delete max k times.
Or I can delete max some number
of times, however many things
that I need.
Right?
If I want log n highest things,
I can just do that log n times,
right?
So for this-- if I had
such a data structure,
I could do this in one
run of this operation
and log n runs of
this operation.
Does that make sense?
I could solve this
problem reducing
to this data structure.
Now, for a sorted array
or a set AVL tree,
this operation kind
of kills me already.
It takes n log n time.
The nice thing
about a binary heap
is, it does this
operation in linear time.
You will see that on Tuesday.
And it does this
operation in log n time.
What's the running time
if I use a binary heap
to implement this
data structure?
Order of n times order
log n times log n.
How big is log n squared--
log squared n-- compared to n?
It's smaller, right?
So if I add those two
running times together,
it's still linear.
That's how you solve
the first problem.
I didn't have to tell you
what a binary heap was
or how it did what it did.
All I needed to
tell you is that it
did this operation
in linear time
and it did this
operation log n time.
All right.
The magic will be shown
to you on Tuesday.
Part B says, now, suppose
Fick's computer is only
allowed to write to,
at most, log n space.
Well, OK.
That's a problem here.
Because before, we copied
over the entire array,
filtered it out, and
then did some operations.
But we couldn't even
afford this if we
couldn't store the whole thing
externally in writable memory.
So we can't do that.
So in some sense, this is a
more restrictive environment.
I can do less things.
It's less powerful than my
previous situation, where
I had as much space
as I wanted to use.
So it kind of makes
sense that I, maybe,
couldn't get the running time
bound that we had before.
Maybe I have to
sacrifice something
because I'm in a more restricted
computational setting.
Now, this is something you
could solve with binary heaps,
but you don't have to.
You can solve it
with set AVL trees.
Does anyone have an idea
of how you could solve
this using a set AVL tree?
I'm limited by my number of--
my space is, at most, log n.
AUDIENCE: So how much space
does a set AVL tree take?
JASON KU: Right.
Space-- there's constant
number of pointers
for each one of these nodes.
And I'm storing in
notes and space.
Basically every data structure
we've shown you takes space--
the order of the things
that we're storing.
It's not using additional space.
It might take more time
to do certain things,
but the space takes
the number of items
that we're storing plus,
maybe, a constant factor.
So I'm going to draw my input
here, which I can only read--
I can't write.
Do I give it a--
I'm just going to call
it A. So this is my list
of all the Revenger opinions.
I can only read it.
But my computer can only write
to this logarithmic amount
of space.
What can I put in that space?
AUDIENCE: The log [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Well, I can certainly
put log n things in there.
So if I'm given
that restriction,
I probably want to build a
data structure of that size,
containing that
number of things.
Does that make sense?
Because what else
are you going to do?
So I gave you an idea.
Maybe we could use
a set AVL here.
I see a logarithm in my answer.
It's very possible that we
might have sorted arrays
or set AVL things.
Those things give me a log
somewhere in my running times,
right?
So kind of makes sense
that I might have,
maybe, a set AVL tree here.
Why would a set AVL
tree be helpful for me?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's sorted and you
don't have the
traversal order, you
can calculate the traversal
order and insert [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: Sure.
I can do all of those things.
But in particular,
it's going to help
me be able to find a
large one quickly, right?
If I have a set of
things, it's going to be--
and I'm maintaining
this data structure
by adding things
incrementally to it,
I can find out what
the biggest one is--
or the smallest one--
pretty fast in log n time.
So if I have log n
things in a tree here,
what's the height of that thing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Log log n.
That looks familiar.
So what can I afford?
I can afford a linear number
of opt set AVL tree operations
on this data structure.
OK, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK, I'm sorry.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For that
to be an AVL tree,
does it have to be a BTS tree?
JASON KU: Uh, BTS--
BSTs.
So when I talk about--
someone likes Korean K-Pop.
OK.
So BST-- but in natural--
kind of in the lingo
that you're probably
used to hearing
in other contexts,
what we mean, in this
class, is a set AVL tree.
Now, sometimes, what
people refer to as a
binary search tree doesn't
have balance semantics--
so what we might call, in
this class, a set binary tree.
But really, they're useful
because they're balanced.
So we're going to
usually just assume
that we're talking about
balanced things here.
Now, a set AVL tree has these
binary search tree semantics
where the keys are ordered.
These items have keys
and they're ordered.
It's a set interface.
Whereas we also presented
to you a sequence
interface, for which these
things don't even have keys.
How could I store
set semantics there?
So that's the
distinction that we
mean when we say binary search
tree versus, really, a set AVL
tree versus [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if we look at it
to make an AVL tree out of this,
would that mean that, when
we make a node, we tell it,
we are keying on the absolute
value of [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: OK, when you're
making a set AVL tree,
you've got to tell us what--
if you're storing objects,
you've got to tell
me what their key is.
You're just storing
some numbers,
like what I'm doing here.
Now, this isn't a set AVL tree.
But if I'm just
storing numbers, I
have to tell you the items
that I'm storing are the keys.
And then everything follows.
But if you've got an
object that you're
trying to sort, like the
students in this room,
you've got a lot of properties.
I want all of the people
with phone number--
maybe I want to key you on
phone number for some reason.
That's going to help me
find out where you live?
I don't-- this is
getting a little--
I don't want to go there.
But if I give you
a set AVL tree,
I've got to tell you
what it's keyed on.
If I give you a
sequence AVL tree,
it's obvious what
my traversal order
is going to be because
I'm giving you a sequence.
That's what the input was.
Does that make sense?
All right, so I've got this
set AVL tree of size log n.
What should it be keyed by?
AUDIENCE: Absolute value.
JASON KU: The absolute
value of their preference--
or of their opinion.
I don't remember
what this is called.
But what log n things
do I put in here?
I don't know.
I don't know anything
about these things.
What makes one
better than another?
Let's just put the
first log n things.
Does that make sense?
All right.
What could that tell me?
Now, I've put this thing in it.
How long did that take?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Log n times
log log n time, right?
But that's much less
than our running time
that we're looking for,
so I don't really care.
I mean, I want you to
say how long it took,
but for my purposes,
I know that it's
lower than the running
time I'm looking for.
And I did that operation once.
I don't really care
about it anymore.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How did you get
the log n times log log n?
JASON KU: Because
the number of things
I'm storing in this
thing is log n.
And so if I pattern match
the build time of an AVL tree
and I stick log n in there,
then it's log n times log n.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So that's
just for one iteration?
JASON KU: Well, right now,
I've just built this thing.
Maybe-- I just built it once.
I'm asserting, too, that maybe
I don't need to build it again.
What could I-- so,
by now, I know--
I haven't filtered
my data at all.
I'm just storing these things
in sorted order in some way.
What can I do to
maybe start processing
the rest of the data?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] try
to scroll through the list A
and try to find someone
that's bigger than--
try to keep the
maximum [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: Sweep this guy
over inserting things,
and always maintaining--
if I do that, and I
keep sticking things
n I'll have this sorted
of thing at the end.
And now I can just read
off the biggest k things.
However, as I'm inserting
things across here,
my thing's growing.
AUDIENCE: Well, just
delete the smallest one.
JASON KU: Oh,
delete small stuff.
I like that idea.
AUDIENCE: So
basically replace it.
JASON KU: Yeah,
Right.
What I'm going to do--
here's a proposal.
We're going to take the
next guy, stick it in.
Awesome.
Which one don't
I care about now?
The smallest one there.
So kick the smallest one out.
Now, this one that
I stuck in may.
Be the smallest.
So I just kind of passed
it through this thing,
but how long did that take me?
It took me the
height of this tree.
What's the height of this tree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Log log n.
So I put one in,
I popped one out.
That's the smallest, right?
And I keep doing that all
the way down the thing.
How long did that take me?
JASON KU: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
Processing n minus log n
things, which is basically n.
And each one of those
operations took me
height of the tree time.
That gives me the
running time that we're
looking for, n log log n.
sense?
AUDIENCE: Is this reminiscent
of a sliding window technique?
JASON KU: Yeah.
It's kind of a sliding
window technique.
You may have been
using one recently.
OK.
Everyone OK with this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you just
remind me of the context
that we're talking about is log
log n, like tree and where--
JASON KU: So this thing--
the size of this thing
is log log n?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JASON KU: I mean-- sorry, log n.
And the height of this
thing is a log of the size.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, in relation
to our little log n size
[INAUDIBLE] small
log log n trees, or--
JASON KU: No, so-- sorry.
I'm taking this stuff--
there's no intermediate
data structure here--
I'm just sticking all of
these things into set AVL.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Into one
set AVL of size log n.
I'm sticking a guy in,
popping the worst guy out.
Going through all of the things.
I need to make sure,
when I'm sticking it in,
I'm keeping track of
which Revenger it is,
and that I'm taking
the absolute value,
and all of those nitty
gritty kind of things.
But that's the basic idea.
I'm just taking this, I'm
sliding the window in,
putting something in,
taking something out
that may or may not-- probably
is not-- the same thing.
And at the end of
this procedure,
the invariant I'm
maintaining here
is that my thing always has the
k largest opinions of the ones
that I've processed so far.
That's obviously true
at the beginning,
when I build this thing.
And when I get to the end, I've
processed all of the things,
and this has size log n, and
so I have the log n largest--
highest-- extremist opinions.
And then I can just do
an in-order traversal
of this thing and return.
Does that make sense?
And I've only used
logarithmic space.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wait, I don't get it.
Are all of the opinions
in that AVL tree?
JASON KU: Are all of the
opinions in that AVL tree?
All of these opinions
are in the AVL tree.
And at some point, I
will insert every opinion
into this AVL tree.
But I'll be removing the
ones that I don't care about
as I go.
Does that makes sense?
I'm always maintaining
the invariants
that this thing, before
I insert something,
has exactly log n items
in it, and then I'm
maintaining that invariant by
sticking one in, taking one
out.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, so then
which one are you deleting?
JASON KU: Always
the min, because I'm
wanting the largest ones.
AUDIENCE: And the min
of the absolute value.
JASON KU: Yeah.
I'm keying by the absolute
value of these opinions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Total runtime here?
It's bookkeeping.
It took me log n
times log log n time
to build this data
structure at the beginning,
plus n times log log n.
I did, basically, n operation--
asymptotically, n operations.
This way, it's actually
n minus log n operations.
And each one of those
tree operations--
doing one insert, one delete--
each one of those took the
height of the tree time.
And so this is that.
Good?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If, instead of one,
we just insert and delete, can
you do a comparison and then--
JASON KU: The
inserting and deleting
a set AVL tree is
actually doing comparisons
within its data structures.
AUDIENCE: Just
compare with the min.
And then--
JASON KU: Sure,
you could do that.
I could do it the other way.
I could remove the
smallest element here,
to start with, right?
And then I compare
it with this guy,
and then whichever is
bigger, I stick it back in.
Same thing.
It's just, am I doing the delete
first and then the insertion,
or am I doing the insertion
first and then the deletion?
Any other questions?
Lots of questions.
All right.
Well, I'm probably going
to have to skip a problem.
We're going to move on to CS--
no, SCLR.
What's the reference here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah, CLRS.
These are four academics
who wrote a popular textbook
in computer science.
This is the same kind
of k kind of thing.
They found first editions and
they want to auction them off.
People can go on
to their website.
They have a bidder ID.
It's a unique identifier.
And they can place a bid
for one of these books.
And they can change it
during the bidding period,
but at the end of
the bidding period,
the academics want
to know who the--
what is the expected
revenue I'll
get by selling to the
k highest bidders?
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
OK.
Note that, before I build
this data structure,
I know what k is.
k is a fixed thing.
Because my running time of this
get-revenue depends on this k,
it's not an input
to that operation.
So k is kind of I don't
know what it is, a priori.
It could be n over 2.
It could be log n.
It could be 1.
But the data structure
I build needs
to satisfy these
running time properties,
no matter what choice of k
that the academics told me.
Does that make sense?
What I need to do is, as
far as time is going on,
people are placing new bids
and updating their bids.
And those updates
can take log n time.
But as soon as I
close the window,
I want to be able to tell,
in constant time, what
the k highest bidders are.
Any ideas on how to do this?
What are the operations
that I have to do?
I have to be able
to place a new bid.
Associated with a bidder
is an idea and a bid,
which is also an integer--
how many dollars I'm going
to pay for this book.
Update the bid.
In some sense, I need to find
whether that person placed
the bid before, in
my data structure.
So at some point, I'm going
to need a find on bidder ID.
Does that seem possible?
So I might want to have
some kind of dictionary
on bidder IDs.
When I say that I want to have
a dictionary on something,
right I'm not
specifying to you yet
how I'm going to
implement that dictionary.
What are my usual options?
A hash table.
But what if I need
worst-case time?
A set AVL tree, right?
That's going to be your
go-to for a dictionary,
because that's going to give
me log n time to find things
via a key.
It's the only thing--
well, except for a sorted--
you could also use
a sorted array,
but that's going
to not be dynamic.
And here, we're updating
who's in my data structure
all the time.
People are going in
and placing bids--
new people placing bids.
So my set of things
that I care about
is changing all of the time.
So that's probably
going to steer me away
from sorted arrays,
because they're not
good with dynamic operations.
So I'm going to need some kind
of dictionary on bidder IDs,
but I'm also going to need
to maintain the sum of the k
highest bidders.
Does that makes sense?
And so, in some
sense, I need to keep
track of an ordered notion of
the bidders, the bids, that
are in my data structure.
Does that make sense?
So order is going to be
important on the bids.
I'm going to need a
look-up on bidder ID.
And that's about it, right?
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just checking.
So if something
that's worst-case
runs at worst-case time,
runs expected [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: Yes.
Correct.
Yeah.
That's a very good observation.
If it runs in worst
case time, it also
runs in expected at time, right?
Because there's essentially
no randomization
that I'm talking about here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Yeah.
And so there's a stronger notion
which we want you to specify,
which is that, actually, there
is no randomization here.
We're not using a hash table.
In this class, really, that's
the only situation where
that's going to be an issue.
But if it is, what this problem
is saying for each [INAUDIBLE],,
whether your running time is
worst case expected and/or
amortized, what we're really
trying to get you to say is
what's the--
evaluate the running
time of your algorithm
with the proper qualifications.
If it took worst
case, I want you
to say that it took worst case.
If it took-- if you
used a hash table,
I want you to say expected.
And if these operations
were sometimes really bad,
but on average, they're really
good-- if I did a lot of them,
that's amortized.
Or if I reduced to
using a dynamic array,
or if I reduced to
using a hash table,
those dynamic operations
would still be amortized.
OK.
The dynamic ones.
The nice thing about
linked data structures
is that dynamic operations
aren't amortized.
So we're going to
be able to get one.
Now, for this problem, we can
actually get worst case bounds,
so we're going to try for that.
You can also do it in expected
using some hash tables
for that dictionary.
When you approach
a data structures
problem in this class,
you want to tell me
what it is you're
storing, first off.
Tell me what's supposed
to be in those things--
some invariants on
this data structure
to make sure that, when
I do queries later,
that these things
are being maintained,
so that if I'm maintaining
a sorted array,
and I'm supporting an
operation to find the maximum,
I had better--
anything I do to
this data structure
had better be maintaining
the invariants
that these things
are in sorted order
and the last thing
has the maximum item.
Because my max-return
thing is going
to look there and return that.
Does that makes sense?
So you want to tell me
what is being stored
at a generic point in
time during your data
structure, what is
being maintained-- so
that, when I support the
dynamic operation or a query,
in a dynamic operation, where
I'm inserting and leading
things from this thing, I
need to make sure that I'm
maintaining those invariants.
And when I'm querying,
I can actually
rely on those invariants
to answer my query.
Does that makes sense?
So, for this
problem-- this is 4-3.
Any ideas?
I have two kind of keys that
I might have to deal with.
One's a bid ID and
one's a bid, right?
So how could I, if I have two
keys that I might want to,
maybe, order on one
and look up on another,
how many data structures do
you think I'm going to use?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JASON KU: Two.
That's a pretty good guess.
So one of them--
let's just guess, right?
I need to be able
to look up on bid,
so let's store these bidders
in some kind of dictionary
that's going to be able to
look up those things fast.
So two data structures.
One is a dictionary
keyed on bidder ID.
What else am I going to want?
What's up?
The other way around, a
dictionary stored on the bids?
Is a dictionary
what I want here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] set
up AVL tree [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: I want to
maintain order somehow.
Because I want to
maintain the biggest
things that I've seen so far.
Right now, if I have--
at some point in time,
what's going to happen?
If I'm maintaining the k
largest at any point in time,
it's possible that
one of those bidders
maybe decreases his bid so
it's no longer in the highest.
I'm going to also need to
keep track of the other guys
to see who I should add back
into that set, for example.
Here's an idea.
I'm going to keep not just one
other data structure, but two
other data structures.
Maybe this is a leap.
You don't have to do this.
There's a way to do it
with just one other.
But I'm going to store two more.
One is kind of an--
a data structure to
store bidders with a--
store the k highest bidders,
and a data structure
to store the n minus
k highest bidders.
Does that make sense?
This separates my problem
quite nicely, right?
Every time someone does an
interaction with this data
structure, I can check
to see whether it's
bigger than the
smallest thing in here.
If it is, I can do the same
kind of trick I did before.
I can remove it and stick
my new one in there.
And we're going--
but I removed it.
I have to maintain
this property.
So I stick it in here.
There's another case.
What's the other case?
It's smaller.
In which case, I
don't do anything
to this data structure, and
I just stick it into here.
Does that makes sense?
What are the operations
these data structures
need to maintain?
Finding the minimum or the
maximum of these two sets.
Does that make sense?
Actually, really, the--
where are those operations?
I don't have them anymore.
But they were the
priority queue operations.
They had delete_max--
and also insert--
were things that it did well on.
So any priority
queue, anything that
can deal with maxes
and mins, is good.
And what's a data
structure you know
that can deal with maxes
and mins pretty efficiently?
The set AVL, right?
So instead of data
structure here, I'm
going to say, set AVL.
And obviously, it's going
to be cheered by bid.
Because that's the thing that
I'm going to want to find
maxes and mins over.
Everyone following
the logic here
of why I'm maintaining
these things?
This is the level
of an invariants
that I want to maintain,
because when I go to,
for example, do this
query, get-revenue,
I can just run through and
sum all of these things.
Oh, wait.
How much time do I have?
Do I have k time?
No, I don't have k time.
So I don't-- I can't afford
to sum up all of these things
at the end of my thread.
I have to return it to
you in constant time.
Any ideas?
Yeah, just compute--
update a sum.
Along with this
data structure, I'm
going to keep a
fourth thing, which
is just total of their bids.
I'm going to call it t.
And that's something
I'm maintaining.
It's part of my data structure.
You can think of it
as, I'm augmenting
this thing with a number.
And the point of augmenting
this thing with a number
is that I can just--
if I need to know what the
total of this stuff is,
I can just look at that number.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So now, I think,
we're almost done.
We're basically done, right?
How do we do this?
Someone walk through to
me how I would get revenue
with this data structure.
I basically kind of told you.
Look at this number.
Return it.
Because that's the invariant
that I've maintained on my data
structure.
I'm relying on this invariant.
Now, I'd better make
sure this is good
when I do dynamic operations.
I make sure I maintain it.
But if I, by induction, I ensure
that all of this stuff is good,
and when I do a dynamic
operation, all of that stuff
is maintained,
then I'm all good.
So get-revenue, after I did all
this extra work, is very easy.
I just look at this
number and return then.
When we're grading a
data structures problem,
usually we give you some points,
first, for setting up your data
structure, separately
from the operations,
and then we give you
points per operation
that you successfully
deal with, and then
some points for correctness
and running time.
Yeah, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: So would
total be a thing
that we update
whenever we mess around
with the highest bidder tree
and then n minus k bidder tree?
JASON KU: I'm sorry,
say that again?
AUDIENCE: Are we treating
the total to an augmentation
that we update every
time we do something?
JASON KU: Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's just one number.
It's not really
a data structure,
it's just one number that
I'm storing with my database.
All right.
How do I implement
a new bid operation?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Can we assume that the
bids will also be unique?
JASON KU: Can you assume
that the bids may be unique?
No.
That's actually something that
is a really useful observation.
We've been talking about
set data structures
as requiring unique keys.
How can I deal with
non-unique keys?
It actually turns
out that, hash table,
it's really important
that these be unique keys.
Because I need to check
whether it's in there.
I'm looking for that single key.
When I find it,
I have to return.
If I had multiple
things with that key,
I might not return the
one that I'm looking for.
Doesn't even make sense.
But you can generalize
the set infrastructure
to deal with multi-sets.
How can I do that?
Well, with each key--
again, I'm storing unique keys.
With each key, I can link it
to a sequence set of structure,
or any other data structure.
And what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to do-- anything
that has that key,
I'm going to stick it
in that data structure.
So instead of storing
one item there,
I have the possibility of
storing many things there.
Now, I have to change
the semantics here.
If I'm saying, find on this
key, well, now, I could say,
I'm going to return all of
the things with that key,
or I'm going to store
some thing with that key.
But you get the idea.
All I have to do is map it
to some other data structure
to maintain [INAUDIBLE].
Like, maybe, I want all of
the things with that key.
I want to find the one
with this other key.
So maybe I link to
a set data structure
that can search on
other things, right?
But the idea here
is, we maintain
this uniqueness key property.
I have to relax my
semantics so that I'm
storing multiple things
at that key location.
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
matter whether the set AVL
tree has unique keys or not?
JASON KU: It's going to matter
here because I have bids.
And the bids could
be non-unique.
Two people could
have the same bid.
And by our definition
of a set data structure,
it had to have unique keys.
So if I stuck in all of
these things keyed by bidder,
you've got a problem.
Now, in actuality,
we can get away
with that by storing,
basically, a linked
list of all of the things with
that key, and we would be fine.
And then, whenever I want to
return one, I could just do it.
But actually, a
binary tree actually
is flexible enough that,
in most implementations,
you can just store a
bunch of those things.
But, actually, our
run times do worse.
What does it mean to
find-next in my sequence?
return the next larger
thing above this key?
Doesn't really make
sense, because there
could be multiple ones.
Which one do I return?
And if I repeatedly do find-next
on this data structure,
I might not loop through
all of the things.
So some stuff breaks
down in our interface.
So I would prefer you use unique
keys in this kind of situation.
Next Tuesday, I think,
with binary heaps,
we'll deal with non-unique keys.
That's fine.
But if you're going to use
non-unique keys in here,
you've just got
to be a little bit
careful about the semantics.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: You would
get the same running
time-- you have to
change the semantics
on what you mean by
"find something."
I just want to return
anything with this key.
AUDIENCE: What if
everything has the same key.
Then--
JASON KU: Then it
takes constant time.
I just return the first thing.
I mean, these are
special cases that you
have to think about, right?
I don't like
thinking about them.
So I just like
having unique keys.
And if I want a situation
where I have non-unique keys,
I'm going to basically
put collisions at that key
into a new data structure.
It's just easier for
me to separate out
in my head on what's happening.
Because, all of the running
times that we proposed,
there's very strong
definitions for unique key.
When you're dealing
with a multi-set,
it's a little bit
more prevalent.
Any other questions?
We really need to kind
of move on here, right?
Dictionary keyed on bidder.
We still haven't implemented
any dynamic operations.
New bid.
What do I do?
What am I going to
need for my update?
I'm going to be able to
need to essentially find,
in each of these
data structures,
where that bidder is.
And if I just have a
thing keyed on their bid,
the interface doesn't tell
me what their old bid was.
It just tells me what
their bidder ID is.
So if I just had their bidder ID
and their new bid, how the heck
am I going to find out
which of these data-- where
in these data
structures they are?
What I can do is, I can
store, in this dictionary--
which I can look up in
some amount of time--
a pointer to where it
exists in these things.
Does that make sense?
This is called cross-linking.
You may have done that
a little bit in problem
set 2, or something like that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Restoring a
pointer to a specific bidder?
JASON KU: Yeah, exactly.
The invariant we
have is that all
of the bidders we've
processed so far
exist in these data structures--
in one of these
data structures--
because we've used
a set AVL tree.
In particular, it
exists in a node of one
of these data structures.
What we can do
is, in this thing,
maintain pointers mapping
each of the bidder IDs
to their location in
these data structures.
And why is that going
to be a useful thing?
Say I map this dictionary.
What could I use
for this dictionary
to get the running
time we're looking for?
I could use a hash
table or a set AVL.
If it's a set AVL, I'm going
to get logarithmic time, worst
case.
With a hash table, I'm
getting constant time,
but it's expected.
So it could be linear
time in the worst case.
We're going to use a set
AVL tree, because that's
what we do right now.
And that's going to
give us worst case.
What I'm going to do is, for
each one of these things,
I'm going to store that pointer.
What I'm going to
do is, first, I'm
going to do that
operation we had.
If I'm adding a new bidder,
I'm going to take the D and B--
these two values, that
object, that bidder object,
or whatever--
I'm going to look at the
smallest thing in this data
structure, see if its bid
is bigger than the thing
I'm inserting.
If it is, then I'm not going
to touch this data structure.
I'm just going to
insert it in here.
And now, after I
insert in here, I
know exactly where it is
in the data structure.
I just inserted it.
So now, holding
that in my hand--
the node-- I can go and
insert that bidder into here
by bid ID.
So it's going to
take logarithm time.
And now I can store, with
that node, my pointer
to this data structure.
Does that makes sense?
And in the other case, I
kind of do the same thing.
If it's bigger than the smallest
thing here, I pop that smaller
thing out, stick it in there,
and I stick my new guy in here,
cross-linking each of those
pointers along the way.
Does that make sense, hopefully?
Kind of?
OK.
And for update, very similar.
If I want to update
a certain bidder,
I look in this data
structure, find the bidder,
traverse that
pointer to wherever
it is in one of these
AVL trees, right?
If it's in this one, I just
remove it from the tree,
or I remove it from
the tree and then
I re-insert with
whatever the new bid is.
And if it's in
this one, again, I
remove it from the tree,
re-insert in whichever
of these things is,
and then I might
have to swap a constant
number of things back
and forth here to maintain
that this has the k highest.
And when I do those
dynamic operations,
I'm always removing
some constant number
of nodes in each of these
trees and adding back
in a constant number of things.
And while I do that, I just
make sure to update this total
as I go.
This total was the sum of
all of the bids in here.
And if I insert a
new bid in here,
I have to add to that total.
And if I remove one, I have
to remove from that total.
But again, it's a
constant number of things
I'm moving in and out of
these data structures,
and so it can update
this in constant time.
Does that makes sense?
Now, the lookup here, and
the insertion and deletion
in here, those each took
logarithmic time, worst case.
But I did a constant
number of them.
So again, logarithm time.
Does that makes sense?
That's, essentially,
this problem.
It's difficult, right?
There's a lot of
moving parts here.
But if you just break it
up and to describe to me--
like, you really do a
good job on this part,
describe well to me what
your data structure has, then
those descriptions
of those algorithms
can be pretty brief, actually.
In this one, you tell me
these three data structures,
you tell me this guy's
mapping to its location
and these things, I'm
maintaining this guy,
and then you just maintain those
things with dynamic operations
and then use those things
for query operations.
Does that make sense?
Wow, we have 10 more minutes?
I'm going to briefly
do 4-4 for you.
Receiver roster.
We've got a coach.
She's got a bunch of
football players--
receivers.
And wanting to
start on her team,
some number of players that
have the highest performance.
And by performance, we
mean the average number
of points they've played
in games that they
have logged in their system.
But actually, their
data is incomplete.
They don't know which games,
and how much they scored,
and all of these things.
There could be errors.
And so these interns,
they're constantly
updating this database with
queries like, oh, never mind,
this person didn't
play in this game,
or actually, they did, and they
scored this number of points.
That's the-- clear
and record things.
And then, at some
point in time, like
when we want to
play a game, I want
to be able to return the
jersey with the kth highest
performance in log n time.
This is kind of a
rank query, right?
The kth highest.
Now, in actuality, I might want
to return all k highest players
so that that might be my roster.
But this is a more
generalized query.
It's more specific, more--
it's not really comparable.
But you get an idea for why that
might be useful to the coach.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
So what's the idea here?
We have a lot of different
things floating around.
We've got games.
They have IDs-- unique IDs.
We've got receivers.
They have unique IDs.
And each receiver could
play in many games.
Oh, that's kind of worrisome.
And many receivers could
play in the same game.
These kind of
many-to-one mappings
are a little confusing.
And then we've got each player--
receiver-- having a certain
number of points per game.
And we're trying to sort them,
kind of, by their performance,
which is a rational number.
Ugh, right?
Which has to do with the
number of games they've played
and the total number of points.
Now, I see rational number,
I can't compute that.
That's what we're talking about
last problem session, right?
But what I can do
is, I could store
the total number of
games they played
and the total number
of points they have.
And you can imagine,
by augmentation
similar to this, every
time I add a game, one
of these small operations, I
can update that information
for each player.
If one of these
dynamic operations
is affecting only
one receiver, I
can update whatever it
is in constant time,
probably, if I just store
with the player what
their total number of games
is as recorded by the database
and how many points
they've scored.
Then, if I have a
data structure that
needs to sort the receivers
by their performance
so I might be able
to find the kth one--
the kth largest-- then I can't
compute that performance.
But what can I do?
I can compare two players based
on their performance using
cross-multiplication.
Because I have the
numerator and denominator
of each of these
rationals and I can
cross-multiply and
figure out whether one's
bigger or smaller.
And as long as I
have a comparitor,
I can do set AVL stuff.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
I'm just going to outline kind
of the components of this data
structure.
Well, first off, I'm going
to need to record a receiver.
And a receiver could
have a lot of games.
But the important-- this is
kind of a receiver-centric kind
of problem.
Does that makes
sense to you guys?
I'm not ever wanting to
filter on all of the receivers
playing a game.
I'm never removing a
game from the system,
I'm removing a
receiver from ever
playing in a specific game.
Does that makes sense?
So if I'm storing a
receiver, and each receiver
has some games
associated with them,
kind of makes sense I might
want to have a nested data
structure where with--
maybe I have a
dictionary on receivers.
And for each one, I
store all the games
that they've played in
some other data structure.
With each receiver, I store
another-- its own data
structure containing
all of its games.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so that's the idea.
We have some kind of--
I need to be able to
look up receivers,
because I'm clearing them
or I'm recording them.
So I'm going to have
a dictionary or--
here, I'm looking for
worst-case log n time.
So I'm going to skip the
dictionary abstraction
and go straight for the set AVL.
AVL keyed on receivers.
I before E, except
after C. It is I--
E-I?
That rule never works.
OK.
Set AVL tree on receivers,
and each one of those nodes
with each one of those
receivers, I'm going to store--
for each, store a
set AVL on games.
Why do I store a
set AVL on games?
Why don't I just store a
list of all of the games?
Because if I want to remove
this game from a receiver,
I need to do that in log n time.
And here, what we're saying is
that n is the number of games,
but that the number of
receivers on the team
is always less than
the number of games.
If I search in this AVL tree
and I search in its AVL tree,
I can be assured that those two
searches was only log n time.
Because I need to
remove game, right?
So there you go.
Then what am I doing?
I'm returning the kth
highest performance.
Well, I need-- with each one
of these guys, I also store--
what was this augmentation?
The sum of the points
stored in these games.
Sum of points and--
what was it-- number games.
Because if I store both of
those things in constant time,
I'm going to be able to
compute their performance,
where I'm going to be
able to have the data
I need to compare performances.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Yeah, it is.
Just numbers.
These are data structures.
This is a data structure.
These are just numbers.
And I'm storing that
with each receiver.
But that's not going to help
me find the kth highest player.
None of these things are
sorted by performance.
So I need a last data structure.
Five, I need to store
something dynamically sorted
by performance.
AUDIENCE: Set AVL?
JASON KU: Set AVL, yeah.
Set AVL storing receivers
keyed on performance.
Now, when I say
keyed on performance,
you want to mention
something about
the cross-pot multiplication.
Like, I'm storing, with
each one of these things,
this augmentation, and when
I'm comparing two things,
I'm using cross-multiplication.
But other than that, then we
can abstract it away, right?
We've abstracted
that function call.
And I can imagine
comparing two keys.
I can do this.
This is a theory thing.
I'm not asking you
to implement that.
But that's sufficient for me,
as a reader of your solution,
to be able to say, yeah, you
know what you're talking about.
All right.
How do I connect these things?
The thing is, I'm
going to need to be--
I need to update these things
when I insert or remove a game.
So how do I know where are these
receivers are in this thing?
I store a pointer into
this data structure, right?
So up here, I store
a pointer to where
it is in the data structure.
Again, I'm storing
all of the receivers.
This has the same size
as the number 1 data
structure up there-- has the
same number of receivers.
But we're not quite done
yet, because I'm not
wanting to know who has
the best performance.
I want to know who has
the kth best performance.
Ugh.
How do I find the kth
best thing in this tree?
I've got a tree.
Set AVL tree.
It's mapped on performance.
I know where the last one is.
But if I want to find
the kth one from the end,
how do I do that?
It's an AVL tree--
a set AVL tree.
All I'm storing is heights.
Is there an operation
that you've thought about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you're
not storing the size of each.
JASON KU: A set AVL
tree, by default,
does not store sizes, right?
That's what a sequence does.
But you think maybe that would
be helpful in this situation?
Yeah.
So, actually, if I decided
to augment by sizes also,
I could do the exact same kind
of sequence find_at operation,
and I could be able to look
up the n minus kth item
in here using the exact same
function for subtree at that I
had in the sequence
AVL tree stuff.
Actually, in CLRS,
they don't even
bother with sequence AVL trees.
They go straight to, if I wanted
this rank-find functionality
on a sorted order
of things, then
I could augment
the subtree sizes.
But it's actually a much
more useful general property,
so we decided to present it to
you in the context of sequence
AVL trees, because then I
can just basically reduce
to it when I get to here.
So that's kind of a
structure of a data structure
that work on this problem.
I leave it to you as an
exercise to implement
all of these operations
for yourself,
or take a look at the solutions.
The last one is going
to be put online--
the solution.
It's pretty complicated.
It's what's called-- you can
think of the size augmentation
finding-rank as a
one-sided range query.
It's basically, how many things
are to the right of this value?
What the last problem
does is walks you
through a two-sided
range query, where
I want to know how many nodes
are between these two values.
So it's a walkthrough.
All right.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.